mouth please
um kaleila
one of our joys in life is we watch um
the voice
if you don't know i'm obsessed with any
kind of talent show
showcase auditioning kind of show i like
it i love when people rise up i like
when people handle pressure and deliver
and this year on the voice it's very
good price
this guy named dave dave finley dave
finley yeah yeah he's a beast this guy
he's the best he's got a grout growly
grizzly kind of a voice
so that's why bobby likes travis strip
because in his audition he sang a travis
tritt song but then he's also really
versatile because his next song was
lionel richie yeah but there was it
if you haven't seen the voice there's
like different stages there's the
audition you get through the audition
the blind auditions
you go into this thing called battle
and then you go and um
you know you knock out or bite knockouts
is battle first and then battle and then
knockouts and the knockouts
i saw we we saw the best knockout it's
somebody fell out it was like a
three-man knockout for kelly clarkson's
team
here's another thing about
i had no idea who the [ __ ] kelly
clarkson was i don't know who
beyonce is i don't know
i don't know her yeah yeah marie carelli
i don't know makeup live yeah i don't
know mary kerry i don't know beyonce i
don't know um who else what's the other
one called the other one let me just
don't even tell me don't throw what name
this season no just in general just let
me artist yeah
uh
christine aquila we have to try to guess
it kill it christina quilla aguilera
christina aguilera aguilera babe you
knew that aguilera yeah
what else and then what's the other
one's name is um
i forget
but anyway i don't know who these people
are very caring beyonce any other but
the thing is is that this show
it you know here when i grew up i
haven't talked about this yet which part
when i grew up listen guys when i grow
up i was exposed
no just just
you know obscure really cool stuff you
knew
he just channeled his energy [ __ ]
stop stroking your own dick bro
we get it you have good taste in music
but it doesn't you know what i'm gonna
say this he's pretty when you when you
laugh bryce
i see more gums and teeth
i see more gums and teeth and i don't
ever wanna i saw that comment i saw it
all right i don't want to see your
gingivitis
okay all right so close your mouth all
right take it
is that what i'm doing i'll laugh with
my bell shut yeah all right you [ __ ]
driscoll boy why you have redirected
rage your rage should be towards me no
no no no
i said it he did i don't know he he
laughed okay
so anyway um
i grew up with um not just you know
just a particular type of music that i i
listen to
and i always didn't like like r b
or or people that are just vocal i you
know i was more singer songwriter more
you know bands i play people play
instruments may i also comment that
you went to
a predominantly an extremely white
school yep
and you had no black friends growing up
so that's unfortunate for you that you
weren't exposed to hip-hop properly you
weren't exposed to certain types of
genres yeah but you don't can't really
tell though that i grew up in that area
because black i can tell
i always go what's up dog yeah
chill whatever [ __ ]
i'm cool with it or whatever yeah but my
point is is that um so you can't really
tell
not from the suburbs you know
what up what up when you don't want to
see jamaicans or whatever
when i see you [ __ ]
may have a coconut sir what up
what up what up you know i only know one
jamaican
in edwards
anyway um but anyway um
but i'm really you know
people that can sing
good have control i'm really i'm getting
into it as my as i get older you know
you know i've always liked classical
i've always liked because i played the
piano so you know i was always taught
beethoven but mozart rockwell you know
but like i never got into that but i'm
really excited about it so when i listen
to beyonce and all that stuff
it's great man to the left to the left
all that yeah i love it
um and i love the voice it's a great
show and i love adam devine
no no what eleven
i like
yeah i like travis tritt on there
no i know no one's his name let me get
his name blake shelton
blake
i stumbled upon that clip and i was like
this guy's so cool oh she's so good away
yeah no i don't think he's gonna win i
think that dave finley is gonna him and
dave are both on his team though
and they're gonna be the the last three
one of the last three also there's a 13
year old um black girl named kennedy i
don't know if i saw her yeah
johnny for jennifer hudson's team okay
and she is a beast but
there's some good ones in here man
kimberly though the the kai kimberly joy
that whole run
it's a great show um in fact i would
have what do i say whenever i watch the
voice
this is the greatest show no no about
about the job that i want oh that's
right he wants to take over carson
daly's job
oh that'd be a fun job i i'm not even
[ __ ] lying like he already prac we
rehearse
ourselves after each performance we we
um do this um we pretend like we're one
of the judges so we give like critique
to the um the singers okay jennifer
what's your final answer and then we we
do that we rehearse his carson daily
yeah yeah yeah really yeah i need that
job
and i would i don't i wouldn't be funny
i wouldn't be i would just do it real
i'll read it off the teleprompter
you know and also i want to cheer with
the family the family you know i mean
like when a chair turns like
congratulations
yeah i want to say that you know
but i love the voice and here's another
thing i wish you used to be in the ask x
factor oh yeah yeah and then every time
every time i watch the x factor i would
tell kalai let's go
yeah but you know i like x factor better
because it's like you know
these are people that aren't singers at
all and their dreams are coming true
yeah because they're more like you know
i'm a bus boy and you know he had never
seen the voice i've never seen the voice
before oh okay as soon as i switch over
the voice i can't watch x factor it's
[ __ ] garbage
it's a little it's over the top
i like to sing a song it's a old
spiritual song and i think it's from the
bible
well i heard there was a secret chord
that david played and it pleased the
lord but you don't really care for music
dude
no
halloween it's acapulla
guys
well it goes like this the fourth the
fifth the minor fall and the major lift
the baffle king composing hallelujah
all right
finish it nah
you know what when you interrupted me
during the song that made you it made me
mad
dude i'm so sorry why did you do that i
thought i was going to chime in with you
you said you corrected the word you go
it's supposed to be hallelujah but it
wasn't oh
[ __ ] up no he said it's hallelujah i
said the name is called hallelujah
during the song you name the name of the
song yeah
yeah i know it's a song i'm the one that
looked it up all right you don't think i
you don't think that i know you don't
think that i know what the song is let's
start all over
you want to start a little bit oh
i'm not alone
you're right beside my face
would you love me this way
cause i'm dancing with my eyes closed
okay it's me babe
[Music]
one more time for my taste oh hold on
wait for the beat to drop
[Music]
okay that's enough
um that's a new album by a new band
called rye it's not a new album it's a
new it's also a new band called rye i
just discovered them he had one song
it's called taste and she is wonderful
he it's a he whatever how can i just let
you walk away
and let you live without a
when i stand here taking every breath
with you
do i i told you not to laugh dude
i have to start over now
god i'm sorry how can i just let you
walk away
just let you leave without a trace
when i stand here taking every breath
with you
oh
you're the only one who really knew me
at all
just take a look at me now
okay that's it
do the whole song no [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it you should sing the dan hill
song but in a manny pacquiao style yeah
sometimes when we thought
welcome to tiger belly my name is my
name is bobby lee you forgot i just
really know i just realized it
wait
oh like oh [ __ ] i just realized who i am
just listen okay you have your podcast
correct
um are you auditioning for things you're
writing things or what i wrote a script
that we're going to try and uh pitch
here soon a movie a dark half hour
drama oh good um it's kind of like a
little breaking bad ish it's just kind
of like yeah good good yeah so we'll be
pitching that i'm doing i have a band
it's a bucket list we're changing the
name of the sandwich if anybody has a
name out there they'd like to throw out
right now we're thinking left on laurel
we're thinking the lookouts we're
thinking something but the sandwich was
just too i feel like you should leave it
up to him to name your name my band me
yeah
it's got to be something not too funny
not too cool something like oh that's a
nice name
article
oh that is a good name feels good
article yeah article i've always wanted
to be a band called article
yeah article's a good one kimmel will
you uh email it to me
because if it's not a it's not a joke
it's a real band i mean look it's a
bucket list thing we started playing in
my basement no one knew how to play any
instruments i played guitar my friend
played league guitar he's really good
the rest of them i'm terrible no no i
could play something you want to hear
something yeah i'd like to hear it one
of my so
some of my friends why don't you just
write your own [ __ ] and i go you know
what yeah i'm going to write i'm going
to [ __ ] write it and it's a bucket
list that people hate it i don't give a
[ __ ] i have a song i played on my guitar
band and i'll show you my songs
well now you're gonna battle the man
it's not one i don't want to what you
you don't want up me i'm not one-upping
you what's this name bobby what article
right no
have michael play his first
i don't know i'm not i'm not in a band
i'm a solo artist and what's your soul
what's your artist's name artist name
yeah
i'm going to play them
oh do you want to hear it there's a good
one all right
[Music]
is that really a song yeah i love it
it sounds 80s
uh i can't compete with that
it's good listen to you i can't complete
that let's do it this is more like no
let's do it let's do it don't justify it
it's art it's more like seven art beach
music i love beach music all right are
you singing yeah
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
everybody everybody everybody welcome
to another edition of a tiger belly
[Music]
i'm
bobby lee
yeah
we got
dude i don't know dude we have to start
over now because you're laughing at me
dude don't let me just say something
right now dude this is a holiday it's a
holiday edition dude oh yeah i mean this
is about the jesus you're right you're
right so you start over five four three
five five four four three three two
one
[Laughter]
waka waka waka waka waka welcome to the
tiger belly podcast welcome to the tiger
belly podcast
you know i don't you know i try not to
stoke the fire
because i am a weaver of things and um
silence
can we get that one more time oh god
damn it i really i feel like i need the
song again i need it myself
i need to sung myself against too okay
so here we go
silence is a vortex they actually traps
laughter
you sing the second part
i don't know what that means but it
means something
everybody together yeah yeah
um
i feel like you're like the modern day
bach
yeah baroque
that's a horrible combination i'm men no
i'm broke
four three two one you say you want to
cry
but your tears are dry
that was a little snippet of uh
of an album i was recommended
from um
some people a guy named jason tebow he's
like skinny scarecrow white guy
i think he's almost homeless but he's a
podcaster have you you know who he is
you do yeah yeah yeah yeah that one with
um sam tripoli yeah yeah he looks like a
magic man like if you were in a forest
and he he has like little beads that he
sells you like seeds but rare seeds
we wear seeds from stardew valley
tears be dry though they can be
they crystallize in your eyes oh oh
science
and nick youssef you know the persian
guy that i know yeah
he's done this podcast right yeah
no he hasn't yeah
well he'll never do it
if you've done steve's ty siegel's new
album goblins what is it called freedom
freedom freedom freedom's goblin is so
good everybody hey welcome to an e-show
he created that show metallocalypse you
know that [ __ ] oh i have it on blu-ray
okay
and uh
you know a bunch of other stuff and you
know he does all that funny things
and then uh my good buddy chad culchin
oh
also all his albums written i have
yellowstone on national park
fever sky fever i have um yeah you got
duncan pride oh that's a great album it
was a double album dunkin pride yeah
duncan probably
remember the remember the track remember
the donut track don't know we are pride
we got donuts
i love all that take it dunk it chew it
[Applause]
yeah yeah
and guys uh about it i don't know
a year ago maybe or nine months ago not
a year ago whatever
just it doesn't matter people don't
[ __ ] know the truth okay that's true
they could they they don't know the
[ __ ] truth so it doesn't even matter
i could see i'm sorry okay we've got
some beautiful kids here and um i want
to ease into it um
about two years ago
i was laying in my bed i was listening
to some music
and what i do when i lay in bed i'll go
to my you know there's the it i paid
that extra itunes where i get everything
for free it's like spotify oh yeah right
so i you know i i you know i listen to
this i listen so i was listening to
someone orbison
and then i think it
then it went to this other band called
the roon brothers and i go who are these
little [ __ ] [ __ ] nuts yeah
you know when i saw a little thing oh
these are [ __ ] nuts yeah i might not
even listen to these [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're from england off hoity-toity and
[ __ ] when i pushed play on the thing
it started i literally i'm not kidding
you i was laying i was ellie with shades
of blue was that the song literally i
was like
i opened my eyes like this
and one tear of an eye came down my face
like this a slow tear like one
tear per eye
went down my face
and i go holy [ __ ]
that was real
and then i listened i i saw the video of
that right and your face looks so shiny
in the beginning
there's something shiny about your face
just glistening you know what i mean you
almost look subhuman i love it you know
what i mean and your cute little brother
you know thank you and i talk
no no no no stop
yo let me say something to you rupert
in england are there are there rules in
england
rupert look at me are there rules in in
instructions in england the uh so
apparent apparently when somebody pays
you a compliment you have to say thank
you
i'll let that slide down thank you i'll
just say yeah that's it stop okay okay
no
all right i'm gonna do it in a second
and you can talk all you want
all right [ __ ] bloke
culture like
hooligans and my [ __ ] dad
anyway um
and i've been telling everybody about it
room brothers room brother everyone i
could make kaleilas into it he was a
little too excited because the next day
he doesn't usually wake me up for
anything yeah because he knows he'll get
the wrath yeah but he was like he knows
like i'm a big fan of roy orbison or
anything
like that like that
and so he's like sweetie wake up you
have to hear this song he was that
excited i'm not this isn't an
exaggeration of all the things he's told
me to listen to he was most excited
about you boys okay we got to introduce
them because they want to say that henry
wants to say stuff so
he's just smiling and he's staring at us
shiny but um let's get into some other
things before we do introduce them um
said that they're a little bit more
uncomfortable i i like that all day i
like that old thing
and so i told uh her and i told a bunch
of comedians i said it on this podcast
roon brothers
and people really it really gener
um it generated some sort of feeling out
there man and and then all of a sudden i
found out that kalila or somebody was in
touch with you guys
and just give me like warm fuzz all over
my dick man you know i mean not in a gay
way that i don't mean that in a sexual
way but i get more fuzzies in my dick i
get it yeah okay it's a fuzzy feeling
and it's warm
and it's in the tip of my dick
okay and when i come that's what i feel
and that's honest truth and that's real
talk
okay rupert okay anyway so anyway so
then i get a call no no but kalala says
they're playing they're playing and i
went and saw these boys saturday night
at the troubadour right
and boy dude did i did you see me dance
i did you're dancing i was dancing wait
hold on you're not speaking yeah yeah i
almost asked you did you see me dance i
danced like i was watching the pixies
for the first time your hips don't lie
baby yeah my hips were [ __ ] grooving
the tip of my dick was doing the warm
fuzzy thing too as well and i don't know
where that's from i might any therapy
right
yeah but and and i want to say this too
when you listen to people on the um
on the radio or you know you have a cd
or whatever you're listening to the
music
a lot of times their live performances
don't match up
to the recording right
these guys blew me [ __ ] away dude
cute as [ __ ]
so good
it reminded me though of
it's like evergreen music is what it is
okay so anyway i'm gonna introduce you
guys
all right so anyway they're from europe
that's fancy that's fancy as it is we've
never had anyone from europe on the show
name one no no one from europe on this
show dude dude we're getting fancy bro
this is a lot right and um
henry and rupert
stansberry
yeah
yeah
am i not right what was the last name
again
what did you tell me again stencil
stancil that's what i said and let me
start out saying we say that again
henry and ruben stancil
that that's pretty good that was pretty
good right pretty pretty thank you for
that lovely introduction yeah